i
[Música]
que se les viene a la mente cuando
escuchan creatividad
si ahorita google amos esa palabra y nos
vamos a la sección de imágenes
seguramente nos encontraremos con
elementos coloridos dibujos gente
pintando etcétera
y es que lo largo de los años nos han
venido a esta falsa idea de que las
personas creativas son aquellas que
tenemos una vocación artística pero yo
creo que es diferente yo creo que todos
podemos ser creativos no importa tu
profesión tu nivel socioeconómico ni
mucho menos tu color de piel por ejemplo
este profesor que se las ingenió para
enseñar los alumnos a usar word sin ni
siquiera contar con equipos de cómputo
porque tal los albañiles que a base de
malabares hacen de todo para conseguir
que la obra quede al 100
hasta en el fútbol existe un jugador que
juega la posición de creativo que a
través de algún paso jugada inesperada
puede resolver un partido
o qué tal este caso que ocurrió hace
poco en un hospital en méxico donde por
falta de recursos los médicos se les
tuvieron que ingeniar para usar un
garrafón de agua como un efecto de
invernadero y así cuidar salvar la vida
de una pequeña recién nacida y es que si
algo me queda bien claro es que los
mexicanos somos creativos por naturaleza
lo llevamos en nuestro adn como el amor
a los tacos o la salsita picante es más
somos tan creativos que hasta inventamos
nuestra propia palabra para la
creatividad
la mexicana la la mexicana da son todas
estas soluciones improvisadas para
problemas cotidianos les voy a poner un
ejemplo usted es un organiza en una
carnaza con sus amigos y el mero día se
dan cuenta de que no hay asador se va a
ser o no se va a ser la carnita asada
claro que se va a ser simplemente
acostamos ahí un carrito de super
ponemos la carne está la marina mos y
ahí está el fregado o por ejemplo van en
el autobús y ya sigue su bajada pero no
sirve el timbre se van a quedar ahí para
siempre
no basta con a presionar el pollo y
listo bajan
hacer más de dos vueltas para cargar con
el mandado del super jamás te hablas a
tu comadre y una escoba y con eso se
resuelve
o qué tal este taquero que no le
envidian a los de uber y después con su
triciclo y su trompo ya puede llevar sus
taquitos al pastor a domicilio
y esque
hasta para poder
por el poder evitar que nos cobren
sobrepeso de equipaje existen mañas y es
que podríamos dominar el mundo si así lo
quisiéramos
y que me queda claro que realmente la
naturaleza de la creatividad radica en
resolver un problema usando los pocos
recursos que tengamos a la mano esto lo
hermoso de la creatividad entre menos
dinero tenga es más probable que
recurras a ella ya lo decía el foro
económico mundial que la creatividad es
una de las habilidades que deberían
estar desarrollando los profesionales
para los empleos del futuro pero bueno
no todo se trata de tener ideas
ingeniosas también hay que saber qué
hacer con ellas
ahí lo dice la misma palabra hay que
saber crear con ellas y creo que ahí es
la parte donde a muchas personas se les
empieza a complicar dar el primer paso
aquí les pregunto cuál creen que sea el
principal enemigo de la creatividad
este sin duda tiene que ser el miedo y
es que decía joseph hilton que para
llevar una vida creativa tenemos que
perder el miedo equivocarnos y es que el
momento de crear nos exponemos ante los
demás exponemos nuestras ideas exponemos
lo que somos y la gente pues él tiene el
derecho de dar una opinión o burlarse o
tenemos miedo al fracaso
y es que la creatividad es un acto de fe
para poder crear primero hay que creer
la creatividad requiere ser valiente ya
sea desde que te animes en una junta a
dar una idea loca que se te ocurrió
hasta renunciar a tu trabajo estable
para poder hacer ese proyecto que tanto
te apasiona la creatividad requiere
huevos
y es que cosas sorprendentes pueden
ocurrir en el momento en el que te
atreves a crear en ti mismo les va a
contar la historia de un pequeño niño
introvertido se ponía rojo a la menor
provocación
era tímido no le gustaba hablar en
público pero eso sí este niño tiene una
gran imaginación y encontró en el dibujo
la manera de expresar todo aquello que
callaba spoiler alert ese niño soy yo y
es que desde que tengo memoria me ha
encantado dibujar me la pasaba dibujando
dinosaurios personajes de caricaturas
smash mis papás hasta en navidad me
regalan un paquete de 100 hojas blancas
y yo con esto estaba más que encantado
recuerdo cuando estaba en secundaria en
vez de exponer atención a mis enemigos
las matemáticas prefería pasarme la
dibujando historietas de mis amigos de
los profesores o hasta la chava que me
gustaba en estos tiempos no existía
facebook por lo tanto el botón de
compartir era que cerró lara la libreta
por todo el salón yo hacía esto con el
simple objetivo de hacer sonreír a las
personas que vieran las ilustraciones
cuando llegó el momento de escoger una
carrera no tenía la menor idea que
quería estudiar me para paramédico y
mamá era representante un laboratorio
por lo tanto estudiar la carrera de
medicina seguramente los llenaría de
orgullo y aparte me abriría las puertas
en el momento que pudiera ejercer pero
pues la verdad a mí no me gustaba y yo
con solo ver sangre ya me estoy
desmayado bajo la premisa de que si voy
a hacer algo durante el resto de mi vida
quiero que sea algo que me apasione
escogí estudiar diseño gráfico porque
sabía que ahí podía dibujar aunque mucha
gente fácil me dijo te vas a morir de
hambre no vas a terminar trabajando en
un mcdonalds
en ese momento escojo esta carrera
aprendo a digitalizar mis ideas ya
recordar las redes sociales encuentro un
foro para compartir estas imágenes más
grande que un simple salón de clases
ahora en este tiempo yo estaba en una
relación con una chava de culiacán que
por una estupidez mía ella terminó
conmigo
en ese momento yo entré en una especie
de depresión durante semanas quizás a
saber de nadie no quería hablar con
nadie
hasta que un día un amigo más se acerca
y me dice álex cómo estás y en ese
momento le digo la neta güey me está
cargando el payaso
en ese momento llegó una risa
involuntaria a mí y me pongo a imaginar
literalmente esa expresión por lo que
agarro mi computadora alguna ilustración
y comparta esta imagen me está cargando
el payaso
en este momento como que vuelvo a reír y
esta imagen para mí significó una
especie de catarsis en la que por más
que nos está llevando a la chingada hay
que ver algo positivo hay que aprovechar
el raid comparta esta imagen en mis
redes sociales y mis amigos le empiezan
a compartir los amigos de mis amigos
desconocidos gente de otros estados
gente de otros países en eso todo el
mundo está compartiendo esa ilustración
algunos tales para decir que estaban
crudos otros para que decir que
reprobaron en un examen o hasta para el
sentir de un país cuando un partido
regresó al poder después de 12 años
en ese momento me di cuenta del
potencial que tenía la creatividad
enfocada en las redes sociales como una
idea podía viajar por todos lados y
dijeron que es algo al respecto y empecé
a compartir estas ilustraciones a manera
de hobby
a veces dibujaba juegos de palabras como
ya salió el peine
con típico que te veas
o tal vez hacía algunas expresiones
típicas por ejemplo soy tu flan
la princesa leía
también de vez en cuando me proyectaba
un poco con mis ilustraciones y hacía
expresar el sentir que tenía con cosas
tan cotidianas como el mal del puerco
o cuando se nos sube la cerveza y nos
trata de convencer que busquemos a
nuestra ex
también de vez en cuando me salí a
dibujar uno que otro de mis dedos
existenciales
déjenme un segundito hoy
uno que otro de mis pedos existenciales
y así seguí haciendo esto únicamente por
hobby porque disfrutaba esta reacción
que la gente sonríe al ver estas
ilustraciones
bien decía y steve jobs que la
creatividad consiste simplemente en
conectar cosas y tiene sentido en ese
momento estas ideas empezaron a
aterrizar en proyectos con otras marcas
que me empezaron a buscar para hacer
esto que sea como pasatiempo pero con
ellas y así fui conectando estas ideas y
pues tal vez mostrando que los mexicanos
somos dos bien botanas para una marca de
chile en polvo
también demostrar cuál sería la cita
perfecta de un diseñador gráfico
cómo sería pinocho si hubiera tenido un
celular creo que ha tenido el primer
destino
o hasta maneras de enseñar que pedirle a
alguien que se ponga el cinturón de
seguridad es otra forma de decir te amo
y así estuve colaborando con diversas
marcas haciendo lo que me apasionaba
ahora mi definición favorita de
creatividad le dijo albert eisntein que
dice que la creatividad es la
inteligencia divirtiéndose y es que en
el ocio nace la inspiración cuando era
chico mi mamá me regañaba por jugar con
la comida pero fui creciendo y la comida
no quiso dejar de jugar conmigo y es que
eso cuando gente está por comerse una
galleta yo y veo una flor
bueno un pingüino me puede encontrar a
uno de los típicos rivales y villanos de
batman
o hasta ver que bo esponja vive literal
en una piña
no podía hacerme un sándwich sin
encontrarme peterpan nomás le venían
estas ideas y tenían que encontrar una
manera de proyectar las como cuando te
arrima en el camarón
cuando te hace está malito en la cama
y la que considero mi capilla sixtina
los tacos al pastor
no se preocupen ningún taco fue
desperdiciado en la creación de esta
pieza
y así me fui divirtiendo estos años
haciendo estas ilustraciones estas
imágenes con comida y es que la
creatividad también es ver las mismas
cosas de siempre de manera diferente y
esto logro que con el paso de los años
una gran empresa de productos de oficina
me invitara a un reto a trabajar con
ellos donde durante un mes estuve
haciendo representaciones de elementos
muy mexicanos usando únicamente sus
productos así le di vida a este ajolote
que tenía por anne branquias unos clips
o qué tal la danza típica de los
viejitos en michoacán
o las trajineras de xochimilco realizado
con un set de acuarela hasta usaría el
pincel como remo
los voladores de papantla
el agave de tequila
o aquí el tradicional huipil yucateco
hecho con un montón de post-its y este
ex proyecto fue un éxito pues invitó a
más personas a ver lo fácil que era
crear estas cosas lo fácil que era usar
su creatividad y hasta aprendieron un
otro que otro dato curioso de mexico y
es que la curiosidad es la antesala de
la creatividad
porque el hecho de querer saber de dónde
vienen las más cosas de donde surgen
estas ideas te abre la mente de una
manera impresionante
ahora les quiero contar otra de mis
pasiones es el fútbol y uno de mis más
grandes sueños era asistir a una copa
del mundo fue por eso que en el trayecto
del 2014 yo me la pasaba convenciendo a
mis amigos de que teníamos que ir a
brasil ellos
y como todo buen amigo al final se
rajaron todos
con ese dicho de momento de que álex
chingada si no van ellos pues me lanzo
yo sólo hay que llevar un chorro de
mexicanos con quien acoplar
en ese momento tuvo una especie de
epifanía
no sólo vayamos indoamericanas
por último de brasileños para ver un
chingo de gente de todas partes del
mundo que con las tribus árabes podrían
convivir a no ser por un evento como
éste aunque hacer algo creativo en eso
que nació esta idea de un proyecto
también 32 amigos donde van a hacer esta
playera con el diseño de la copa del
mundo conformaba con la palabra amigos
en todos los idiomas posibles un
objetivo conocer a una persona de cada
uno de los 32 países que participarán
mundial saber un poco de su cultura sus
pasiones qué opinaba de la copa del
mundo y al final regalarlo nuestras
playeras para que supieran los mexicanos
siempre puedan encontrar un amigo
o así como me lancé conecta sao paulo y
empecé a conocer a juan luís hermanos
ecuatorianos que también vivían su
primer mundial toni un fotógrafo de
melbourne que venía desde australia
emocionado
una pareja de colombianos por margarita
que conocí me invitaron a comer junto
con ellos en el mercado de sao paulo y
hasta me dijeron que tenía mi casa en
medellín
también así conocí a veintiún franceses
que le encantó tanto mi proyecto que
está en mi piso unas chelas
ma cristian a una pareja de alemanes que
les fascinaba la lucha y
victoria suiza y juanvi de argentina que
al final me pidió que le cambiara su
tierra argentina por la vida de la
selección
al final la del término sino pirata que
cabra
me di cuenta de cómo viajar
como viajar de sacarte zona de confort
te abre a verla
esta pensamiento que tengo de qué
si quieres viajar a leer si quieres
escribir viajar ahora cuatro años
después una marca me dice álex vimos lo
que hiciste en brasil por lo que si va
se piensa así la denuncia queremos nos
tomes en cuenta para hacer un proyecto y
nosotros que patrocinamos
venga es así como ahora se me ocurrió
este proyecto que ella me reconoce un
mexicano en esta ocasión mandamos a
hacer una chamarra con los colores de la
bandera y la frase en espalda me dicen
los mexicanos que estamos donde sea mi
objetivo en esta ocasión era encontrarme
aquellos mexicanos realizados que habían
ido hasta rusia y que tuvieran una
historia que valiera la pena contar y
compartir red sociales
fue así como conocí a valeria de
veracruz una chava que con todos sus
ahorros se podría dejar sola por todo el
mundo haciendo escala en algún momento
en murcia porque tal octavio que es una
de las pocas personas en el mundo que
puede decir que ha festivo a más de
nueve copas del mundo viendo desde 1982
también conocí a viatri quien también
voy a representar a méxico en el mundial
pero él a través del arte exponiendo sus
pinturas en diferentes muchos de los
cursos
o también estuvo el caso de josé ángel
un cineasta entusiasta que a través de
su cámara fue re coleccionando los
diferentes rostros de las aficiones del
mundial ahorita les voy mostrando cómo
se ven desde los componentes de los
rizos
las clásicas bajadas los señores de a
poquito más arrugados
y es que lo conocí en persona cuando iba
saliendo del partido de mexico versos y
korea cuando a uno me pido el favor que
si me podía tomar una foto a tomar posar
para una foto para él yo acepté con
gusto y esta fue la imagen que resultó
de eso
y después esta vuelta le termina dando
cuenta del mundo cuando torea nos ayuda
a pasar a la siguiente ronda se volvió
girar al punto de que la embajada de
corea la compartió pues mostraba como
que la unión de dos aficiones dice así
como puede vivir nuevamente una
experiencia mundialista conocer gente
sorprendente de dos lados iniciar un
proyecto creativo y hasta que me dieran
primero por ella
y es aquí cuando muchos de estoy seguro
que pensaran que suertudo pero señores
esta no tiene nada que ver con la suerte
todo esto es constancia es el resultado
la consecuencia desde haber grado en mí
mismo para ello puede haber hecho es con
rusia primero me tuve que poner máximo
en brasil con esto de las playeras para
hacer el proyecto mexicana primero tuve
que estar cómodo jugando con la comida
para poder quemar gas lo buscarán para
mis frustraciones en algún mundo tuvo
que apostar por mí por mi pasión de
dibujar y hacerlo todos los días es aquí
cuando los quiero invitar a ustedes a
que creamos de es mismos porque sé que
más de uno tiene una idea de 20 vueltas
y vueltas y vueltas esperando que le den
una oportunidad metal déjense la vida
con las redes sociales estamos en la
época de los creadores no importa si
ustedes es cocinar maquillar escribir
cantar estoy seguro que van a encontrar
la manera para hacerlo porque vale la
pena
porque mírenme ahora este pequeño niño
aquí dando una charla durante todo este
público contándoles como ahora se la
pasa hablando con los conocidos de todas
partes del mundo
y hablar con ese niño y él me preguntará
que si seguimos dibujando yo le puedo
contestar con orgullo que hasta nos
pagan por hacerlo muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]